concerns over the easing of restrictions
meant to keep people safe from the
coronavirus
44 states are reopening in some form
which likely means more people spending
time
outside their homes of those states
nearly half have seen an
overall increase in new cases in the
prior two weeks according to the new
york times
the administration's guidelines for
context for reopening
call for a 14-day decrease carter evans
is in los angeles for us where many
non-essential businesses are reopening
today
despite more than 2500 new cases
yesterday in the state of california
i went from 15 employees to zero
nicole briceno is the owner of two small
boutique clothing stores and says she
had to fire
all her employees when her store
shuttered she's reopening
and doing all the work herself i hope
that my employees could eventually come
back and do it with me
but for the moment we're just trying to
follow
you know orders as closely as possible
in california alone
more than 4.2 million people have
applied for unemployment since
march and more than 10 billion has
already been paid out
california governor gavin newsom says
the virus has sent the state's once
booming economy the fifth largest in the
world
into its worst budget deficit in state
history
as this is a global pandemic and there
is not an economy around the world
that has substantively at least been
immune
but some are ready for the return at g j
flowers in los angeles business is
blooming once again with mother's day on
the horizon owner jorge oliveira is
thrilled to be open ahead of their
biggest weekend of the year one mother's
day one busy week
mother's day they cover a lot they help
us a lot still state officials warn
there are dangers in returning to work
and guidelines like social distancing
and face coverings will need to be
followed
it's a good idea to act as if anyone
could be infected with covert 19
and that you too could be infected at
any point in time
44 states have now eased some
restrictions including texas which
is reopening several non-essential
businesses today
on that list hair salons like the one
owned by shelly luther
she had been jailed for reopening her
store early
but after two days in jail and a texas
supreme court order
luther walked out surrounded by cheers a
free woman
you mean so much to me and this would
have been nothing without you
the massive economic hit across the
country has created another problem
hunger hundreds of people in north
carolina showed up at this
drive through food bank yesterday this
as a new survey released by the
brookings institute showed children have
been hit particularly hard
with one in five 12 years and under not
getting enough to eat here at la's
wholesale flour district they're already
open for business this morning but many
stores reopening now will be curbside
only
and now california's governor says they
know where the first case of community
spread of the virus came from
and it was a nail salon for that reason
nail salons will remain closed anthony
all right carter thank you